bonjour d'aprés installez-vous non non
moi je viens juste vous prévenir que
votre rendez-vous à 5 min de retard à et
je travaille à l accueil et puis trois
ans d'amour oui oui ben oui oui oui
non je te veux vous auriez pu m'appeler
femme mary j à oui bah oui oui je n'ai
jamais vu cette personne
bon qu'est ce que je fais moi même et
c'est mieux de ce côté je faisais un peu
pourri mais à vue et pas mal jours oui
je suis je suis un peu intimidé parce
que je connais la réputation de votre
entreprise
je connais aussi votre réputation merci
dites moi ça pas le trophée éthique et
entreprises du meilleur service rh c'est
incroyable je peux toucher faites vous
plaisir
merci beaucoup
c'est génial de générateurs merci merci
beaucoup
photo droite à gauche oui oui baird
gênant toi tu peux pas leur poser un
accord que je me faisais un film
allez allez après ces décisions ont pris
sa décision voilà je les ai mis à la
poubelle
mon trophée mais pourquoi j'ai fait ça
ces jeux si elle me rend débile à chaque
fois je peux pas je suis son supérieur
hiérarchique
mais si si si je suis désolé j'ai le
droit c'est pas de l'abus de faiblesse
est la droite me dire non allez je
m'invite à dîner
allez boire un verre plutôt à nora café
tir pour commencer voilà un café c'est
bien vrai café alice tu veux bien venir
de seconde balle et précis est ce que tu
veux prendre un café pas si ça va très
bien tu voudrais la copie de la finul
standard tu la connais toi on a fait
l'entretien tous les trois parce qu'ils
associent avec elle je trouve sympa
sympathique mais qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle et plus tard allez tu veux aller
boire un café parce que t'es juste et
ont trop fait j'ai vu non enfin si oui
oui tu sais faut pas se reposer sur ses
lauriers de toujours aller de l'avant
non je
merci borders
je suis totalement coincé là j'ai 12 ans
quoi même pas 12 ans font des tours
nantes aujourd'hui aller alice café café
si tu veux un café bon tu veux un café
enfin tu vas aller boire un café qu'on
aborde un café que je t'emmène par un
café ensemble après le boulot avec moi
enfin le soir donc ça peut être aussi un
verre de vin ou un problème crocs
enfin du lait un bon si tu veux un truc
comme du lait faites moi le lait je le
digère pas très bien un ânon fasse appel
du lait d'avoine on se pose on dit
palais d'avoine en fait on dit boisson à
base d'avoine parce que si on dit l'aide
à voile ça va ça veut dire que ça vient
de façon je n'aime pas le vin j'adore le
vin c'est bien tu pleures du vin
beaucoup de voir qu'au le récit est bas
plus un stuff les boulots alice dans les
week end au bord de la mer tous les deux
tu es nus sur le sable
tu me sourit et tu me dis j'ai toujours
su que j'étais juste trop timide pour te
demander et je te dis je sais et je te
prends la bouche je t'embrasse tu me
prend dans les bras et on roule tous les
deux sur le sable et tu me regarde dans
les yeux et dit ok je demande à bonjour
un char c'est bonjour à vous désolé pour
le retard mais c'est moi ça m'arrive
jamais
[Musique]
il faut déborder maintenant